ممارسه عقاريه مشبوهه ذات الهيئه العمل
العقار في السعوديه الى التحذير من
التعامل مع غير المرخصين لتجنب الوقوع في
عمليات الاحتيال وتحويل المبالغ الماليه
لافراد المجهولين الهيئه اكدت على ضروره
اتخاذ خطوات منها التحقق من ان المسوق
للوحده العقاريه من الوسطاء المرخصين
برخصه فعل اضافه الى التحقق من ان الوحده
العقاريه صدر لها ايضا رخصه للاعلان
العقاري مشدده على ضروره التاكد من منطقيه
النطاق السعري للوحده العقاريه عبر
من رياض انضم الينا مدير الاتصال
الاستراتيجي والمتحدث الرسمي باسم الهيئه
العامه للعقار تيسير المفرج تيسير حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه استاذ
لماذا اليوم تحذر الهيئه العامه للعقار
بهذه الصيغه يعني ما الذي حدث
واجب الهيئه هو التحذير بشكل مستمر لاي
ممارسه فيها مخالفات وفيها ايقاع ضحايا من
المواطنين او المقيمين
بدانا نلاحظ الفتره الاخيره ازدياد حالات
الاحتيال عن طريق غير مرخصين يدعون بانه
مسوقين او استطاع عقاريين ينشطون في
المناطق او الاحياء اللي عليها طلب كبير
في موضوع الايجار يستقون معلوماتهم من
خلال الاعلانات يتصلون على الضحايا يعرضون
شقق للايجار باسعار مغريه
يعني ويواصلون مع المستفيد او مع راغب
الايجار حتى حتى في موضوع انه يلقي نظره
على الشقه او على الوحده العقاريه لو
يبغاها وبعد كذا يتم ارسال رساله له من
خلال عقد ايجار وهنا النقطه اللي حذرنا
منها ايضا الوسط بعدم التهاون باعطاء
بياناتهم لمن يدعي بان مسوق واتاحتها لانه
الوسيط المخالف لا يعفى من المس اذا كان
يغرر فيه او انه مكن من بياناته بجهل لانه
هذه البيانات قد تقود العمليات احتيال زي
ما هو معروف وزي ما هو الان حنا نشاهده في
الايام الاخيره بعد ذلك يحاول ان يغري
الضحيه
من خلال السعر المغري وسرعه الدفع حتى لا
تروح عليها الشقه او لا تروح عليه الوحده
العقاريه وبالتالي يقع الضحيه في عمليه
دفع على الحساب البنكي الفردي وهنا يختفي
بعد ذلك المحتال ولا يمكن الوصول له من
خلال
ومن خلال الضحيه او حتى من خلال الوسيط
اللي مكنه من هذه البيانات والمعلومات حتى
يصل الى عقد ايجار كان عدد الحالات هذه
كبير تيسير بدات الان تظهر لذلك حين بدانا
مباشره برصدها وايضا التعامل معها
والتعامل مع الوسط اللي تم يعني تسريب
بياناتهم الى محتالين حتى نبدا نضبط
العمليه حنا نعول بشكل كبير جدا على
العنصرين اساسيين خالد العنصر الاول الوعي
المواطن كثير من الجهات من البنك المركزي
وزاره الداخليه دائما تحذر من عدم التحويل
للحسابات الفرديه في المعاملات التجاريه
حنا في الهيئه العامه للعقارى تحنى خدمات
الالتحقق سواء التحقق من الوسيطه والمسوقه
او التحقق حتى من الرخصه الى قبر اعلان
ايضا وهذه النقطه مره مهمه وهي يمكن
المحور اللي قد يقي الضحيه ان يقع في
الاحتيال لا تدفع الا عن طريق شبكه ايجار
لا يتم الدفع بشكل مباشر وهو التحويل بشكل
مباشر الى
حسابات فرديه الدفع يتم عن طريق الشبكه
هذا العنصر الاول احنا الاول الوعي
المواطن العنصر الثاني ايضا اللي احنا
نعول عليه هو وعي
باهميه الامانه التي يؤتمنوا عليها من
خلال
اعطائهم الرخصه العقاريه وبالتالي ممارسه
الوساطه لا تعطي احد يسوق نيابه عنك الا
هو مرخص لا تعطي بياناتك لمن قد يدعي بانه
يجلب لك مجموعه من الارباح من خلال تسويق
لعقارات وهميه لن تعفيك هذه من المسؤوليه
وايضا
تضعك دائما في محور الاتهام ومحور
الاستدعاء زي ما هو الان جاري عندنا تم
استدعاء عدد من الوسطه الذين مكنوا
بياناتهم من المحتالين وبالتالي سيتم
حالتهم للجهات المعنيه
العين مش على المواطن يعني كيف المفروض
يتحرك للتعامل مع مع هالحالات وحتى يحمي
حتى يحمي نفسه يعني بعد التحريم البلاغات
تتم طبعا عن طريق الجهات المعنيه في
الجهات الامنيه حنا نتحقق دائما بعد
حالتها لنا نتحقق من موضوع انه هل
الحساب او البنكي اللي تم التحويل عليه هو
من حساب وسيط ولا انه لا يعني حساب فردي
مجهول وبالتالي يتم اكمال الاجراءات عن
طريق باقي الجهات لكن الاهم في المواطن ان
يتحقق دائما تحقق لا يعني لا تنجرف وراء
سعر مغري لوحده عقاريه في منطقه تحقق منها
من خلال منصه ايجار من خلال المؤشر
الايجاري لمعرفه هل هذا السعر منطقي اصلا
لما انت تكون يعني على سبيل المثال انت
تتكلم عن شقق على سبيل المثال اذا قلنا
ايجارها يتراوح من اربعين لخمسين في منطقه
وفي حي معين في الرياض لا تتوقع انه ممكن
فعلا يكون هذه الشقه الجميله اللي انت
شفتها في الصور يكون مثلا ايجارها عشرين
او 15 في شيء غير منطقي تاكد من السعر
المنطقي من خلال المنصه الايجاريه وبعد
ذلك كمل عن طريق منصه ايجار للتاكد من
توثيق العقد وايضا التحويل المالي عن طريق
شبكه ايجار نفسها ممتاز شكرا لك تيسير
المفرج مدير الاتصال الاستراتيجي والمتحدث
الرسمي باسم الهيئه العامه للعقار لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات